-I'm so happy to see you
in person.
-It's amazing to be able
to touch you.
-Yeah, you're real.
-'Cause we were Zoom friends.
-Yes.
-Yeah, when you came on
the show.
And thank you so much
for being here,
and congrats on the cover of
"Vogue," by the way.
-Thank you. Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know, I haven't actually
touched a copy.
-You haven't touched a copy?
-No, I've just seen photos
of it.
-This is real. It's the first
time you're doing this.
Come on. This is a big moment.
-A huge moment.
-Yeah.
-The whole thing was just --
-You look gorgeous on the cover.
-Thank you.
-And I also like this.
Is this your dad,
and is that grandma?
-It is.
-Yeah, look at that. Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
They got to be in "Vogue"
as well?
How did they feel?
-Well, my -- I don't think
my dad or my grandma
understood what was happening.
So, my dad was like, you know,
he came, and then, you know,
they put him in a suit,
and Ghana's really hot,
so he was just like --
[ Panting ]
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-At the end, you know,
I was like,
"Dad, so, like,
how did you feel?
It's 'Vogue.'
It's American 'Vogue.'"
He was like, "Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's something different."
[ Laughter ]
-What?
-Yeah.
-You're in "Vogue," Dad.
But now that it's like on the
Internet, my dad is just like
the whole of my village,
Asikuma, where we're from,
the whole of the village is
proud.
My grandma also didn't really
understand until they put on
her dress,
her Issey Miyake dress.
They did her hair
and her makeup.
And she was like, "Oh, I'm
beautiful. I'm beautiful."
[ Cheers and applause ]
And she just kept saying it.
It was so sweet.
-Come on.
-Yeah.
-I think the last time we spoke,
"I May Destroy You" was right --
coming out, it was brand-new.
-Yes.
-And you went on to win two
Emmys and a Peabody Award.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, it was phenomenal.
-Thank you.
-You were phenomenal.
It was phenomenal.
Did anyone surprise you that
were fans of the show?
-Yes, well, loads, loads. So,
first, it was the Emmys itself.
And to just sit there and have
so many people that I admire
come up and say, "Well done."
But then also, the big moment
was getting home to Atlanta
where I was filming
"Black Panther."
And I entered my house, and
there was a huge bouquet of
white flowers and the note said,
"Proud of you, B.X."
Beyoncé.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, have you ever met Beyoncé?
-I've never met Beyoncé.
I've never spoken to Beyoncé.
So for her to do that
was slightly insane.
I've spent my career sort of
like paying homage to her.
"Chewing Gum Dreams."
"Chewing Gum," sorry --
There's a photo of Beyoncé
next to Jesus Christ that
the central character prays to.
-Yeah.
-I've written articles about
Beyoncé for The Guardian,
but I've never met her, so for
her to do that meant a lot.
And then she released
"Renaissance."
-It's fantastic.
-Which was an album and a half.
-It was unbelievable.
-Yes.
And so I sent her a huge plant
and said thank you.
-You sent her a plant?
-I did, yes.
-So you kind of talk to
each other through plants.
-Through plants, yeah.
And just through the air
'cause I don't know
how she got my address.
-Because she's Beyoncé.
-She's magic.
-God knows where you live.
-Yeah, she's a class act.
Good for you, Beyoncé.
I love that she did that.
That's awesome.
Can we talk about
"Black Panther?"
-Yeah.
-Congratulations.
It's such a big movie.
Are you so excited about this?
-I'm excited and humbled
and overwhelmed.
I think, obviously Chadwick
passed, and it meant that there
was this sort of gaping hole
and a lot of grief in the hearts
of the cast as well as joy.
-Yeah.
-So it just feels --
the emotions are complex.
It's not just, "Oh, I'm excited,
I'm in 'Black Panther.'"
It just feels weighty.
-It's a moment.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But I'm honored to have been
there to support the cast.
-In every article that I read
about you,
about this upcoming movie,
you said,
"I want to set it straight.
I am not the next --"
-Yes.
-"The new Black Panther."
-Yes. I have to keep minimizing
expectations
for the people that,
like, love me.
-Yes.
-Minimize expectations about
how much I'm in the movie.
[ Laughter ]
You know, I'm there. I'm there,
but I'm not, like, panthering.
-Okay, you're not doing --
No, no, you're not panthering.
-No, no, no.
[ Laughter ]
-You're not panthering at all.
Yeah, no.
But this is interesting.
You auditioned for the first
"Black Panther."
-I did.
-And didn't get the part.
-Correct.
I auditioned in like 2012,
I think, when I first left
drama school.
And it was a tape, you know, and
it was probably a very bad tape.
I'd never been on TV.
I'd never been in any film.
So I think I was probably one of
like thousands
of people trying to get a part.
I think -- I think a part
very similar to mine.
-To who you play.
Yeah, you can say who you --
-Yeah, everyone knows that.
-Do they?
-Yeah, yeah.
-There's Marvel people
in the audience.
They're like,
"Don't you say that!"
-Yes. Yes, they're very
Fort Knox on everything.
-Well, we're going to show
a clip.
-Exactly.
-We're allowed to
speak about it. Yeah.
-Yes, exactly.
-This is going to be big.
I'm so happy to see you
in person.
You're just as cool as I thought
you'd be.
-You too, Jimmy.
-Oh, my gosh.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Michaela Coel in "Black
Panther: Wakanda Forever."
Take a look at this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Aneka, where is your spear?
-Shuri gave me these to try.
You know, I like them better.
-Our foremothers gave us
this spear
because it is precise, elegant,
and deadly.
It will not change
under my watch.
-Yes, General.
-I told you not to bring them.
-Oh, come on now.
Michaela Coel, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Black Panther: Wakanda Forever"
is in theaters
and IMAX November 11th.
Zedd and Maren Morris perform
for us after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
Come on back.